well i think what we haven't seen is
evidence of withdrawal uh that has been
claimed by the kremlin
in fact we've seen continued build-up of
things like field hospitals
and strategic weapons systems such as
iskandar missiles deployed so
i i think the reality is i said last
week when i visited moscow is that we'll
take russia its word but we'll judge
them on their actions and you know if
we're going to build up true trust uh to
try and de-escalate this uh incident
what we need to make sure is that we're
not building up troops at the same time
and that is still what we see
and until we see a proper de-escalation
i i think we should all be cautious
about the direction of travel from the
kremlin
i mean we have been told about naval
drills we've seen pictures actually of
those naval drills in the black sea at
least those are pictures from yesterday
what is our latest intelligence
well the latest intelligence is that
basically there's over a hundred
battalion tactical groups off the
russian ground forces that's 60 percent
of the entire russian uh gra land combat
power on the borders of ukraine 130 000
plus
troops both in belarus and indeed
ukraine but also out at sea there's
effectively a significant flotilla of
russian amphibious landing ships and
indeed warships and missile ships and
you know from a ukrainian point of view
they're they're fairly surrounded by a
very large force of ready troops and i
think you know that that continues that
that hasn't they haven't taken the foot
off the gas uh you know readiness is one
of the first signs you always get about
how serious a country is
and if you wanted to inflict
intimidation on ukraine that deployment
is doing exactly that and i think that's
why we're all here at nato today and
tomorrow to try and work together to
reduce
tensions and try and de-escalate but you
know it's a very significant force it's
a force that would overwhelm ukraine
should it be deployed and i think that's
why we need to see clear de-escalation
by the removal of troops
at the same time as entering the
discussion with russia
we were warned um quite severely and
your boss the foreign secretary on the
program yesterday saying that we could
be at war today um and that brits needed
to get out urgently from ukraine
were we failed by us intelligence
look i've never talked about a date
because in all the intelligence i've
seen
that you know dates are not the issue
the issue here is
the significant amount of forces you
know
i've been a soldier when you go on
excise you don't set up huge amounts of
blood banks and hospitals in the field
you don't
move strategic weapon systems designed
to protect other parts of russia
onto the edges of ukraine so the real
indications here have not been a date
the real indications have been the
gradual and steady and significant
buildup of forces into a readiness
posture and indeed into a deployment
posture which we've seen in the last few
days that would
significantly
indicate a incursion into ukraine forces
can only be held at readiness for so
long the russians are better at it than
most they could hold those forces at
readiness for weeks so there's really no
point speculating on a specific date uh
however the there are definitely dates
in the mix but i think it's unhelpful to
speculate because if you do you get
exactly the question you you've rightly
asked which is what if it wasn't today
has it all been wrong
i i can tell you it hasn't been wrong i
can also tell you that you know
judge with your own eyes at the scale of
that russian deployment on the borders
of ukraine and indeed all the press
conferences by president putin it's
pretty clear uh that their intentions
towards ukraine are to change their
behavior and all deed change nato's
relationship with ukraine
and they're doing so at the threat of
invasion and i think that's something
that we as nato are here to challenge
and in order and also to deter
you say that troop placement that troop
deployment on the borders there at least
two borders um could overwhelm ukraine
if they moved uh into ukraine but the
foreign affairs select committee chair
tom tuggenheim himself a military man
saying that 130 150 000 troops whatever
the number is is nowhere near enough to
cause problems severe problems uh with
ukraine certainly not to occupy it
well there's a difference between
invading and holding uh a hundred and
you know 100 battalion tactical groups
hundreds of fighter aircraft
warships out at sea
the russians have overwhelming forces
over ukraine
and if they really wish to inflict
violence and invade they could do that
the ukrainians would put up a brave
resistance i made it very clear to the
russians the ukrainians will fight but
those odds are overwhelming
and no one should delude themselves that
they're not and and you know i'm a i
respect tom a lot but i'm afraid he's
wrong on the scale and the figures of
the military forces on either side of
the equation so what's your advice to
brits that are in ukraine um should they
be breathing a sigh of relief at the
moment or should they still be as
anxious as they were this time yesterday
i think they should follow the foreign
office advice which is you know we are
in a position where uh we don't think
president putin has made a final
decision which is again why we think
those forces are still poised at
readiness
and until that decision is made and
communicated by the kremlin
i think the citizens either dual
nationals or british citizens in ukraine
should continue to follow the
well-considered foreign office advice
and uh seek to either leave or avoid
travel to ukraine
um chancellor schultz um speaking uh
after he'd been to see president putin
saying that he doesn't think that
ukraine should be allowed to join nato
we also heard from
general richard dannett he used to be in
charge of the army as you know he also
said the same thing are they both
speaking out of turn
well i think
my understanding of what chancellor
schultz said was that
it wasn't uh you know nato ukraine's
succession to nato was not
on the agenda uh i mean
nate ukraine is on a path towards
joining nato but at a path that is
obviously a very long term path they are
currently an enhanced
partner to nato
but of course nato is fundamental policy
is an open door policy that we will
accept applications and consider as the
30 members anyone who wishes to choose
to join nato we do so in accordance with
our values that is a very important
principle of nato nato collectively
reaffirmed that including the germans
only recently in the response to the
russian government uh so that is the
german position it's the british
position and it's all 30 nations of nato
so it's exactly the same that we have an
open door policy
and uh you know we we engage with those
countries that wish to join us
i wonder if you could clarify words are
important of course you said in the
sunday times a whiff of munich it caused
quite a lot of upset at the time what
did you actually mean by that defense
secretary were you suggesting we're
heading to uh world war iii or we should
be concerned about appeasement
well no i think so okay what i said was
if ukraine was invaded there would be a
whiff of munich because in the munich
conference with adolf hitler in
the late 30s and there were two parts so
one of his appeasement was effectively
where france and britain were very
worried in those days obviously about
the consequence of a further war having
suffered through the first world war and
that is a you know a long uh
covered historical event but the other
part of the munich was the clear
deception by adolf hitler he had a plan
already to expand way beyond uh you know
the the parts of the czech republic he
was after it was a effectively a
deception and while everyone was running
after the straw man
off this argument about just give me a
little bit of border dispute resolution
he was planning a completely different
agenda and i've been very consistent on
uh president putin that i have felt that
part of the argument about being
encircled by nato is in fact a straw man
i wrote an article a few weeks ago about
that and the danger is we all coalesce
around this argument while all along if
he invades nato uh invade sorry ukraine
it would have been a clear sign that he
had a plan all along and you know what
we're seeing at the moment is a clear
plan i mean he has massed thousands of
forces on another country's borders
and that doesn't quite look like
uh uh the the fears he has about nato
given that ukraine is not in nato
it looks like a similarity so that was
what i was trying to say
i did say
i think some of the media took a
different angle on it okay we must let
you go defense secretary i know it's a
very busy time for you thank you very
much indeed for spreading the time to
join us on sky thank you thank you